hey guys welcome to the swish world led
podcast and a special welcome to all the
new listeners who have come over from
the snz platform what a lad has now
partnered up with scnz so i'm super
excited to see how this relationship
develops over the next wee while but as
always this water lad episode is brought
to you by swish super grateful to have
swish on board as the major sponsor of
the podcast and if you don't know what
swish is it's an awesome platform where
you can get a video message directly
from one of your favorite sports stars
it is the perfect gift idea for any
sports lover and there's sports stars
all around the world on there already
the best thing about it all is that up
to 70 of the proceeds do go to kiwi kids
charities so you can feel really good
about your purchase
and just for being a world lead listener
you can get 10 off your order by using
the code what a lad with no spaces i'll
leave a link in the description so just
go click on that if you can to check it
out also if there's anyone listening who
is suffering from muscle or joint pain
then i have just what you need pure
sport is offering 20 off all of their
products if you use the code water layer
20. they are the most tested and trusted
cbd oil in the world some of the biggest
names in sports swear by it as it's the
ideal recovery tool or just to help you
get away from the harsh effects of the
constant anti-inflammatories
if you're keen to try it head over to
puresport.com or click the link in the
description
and lastly don't forget that there's
still plenty of water led hats and
waterlet hoodies in stock so go get
amongst those if you're keen to support
and i'm very appreciative of all the
support this podcast has had so far keep
sharing keep liking keep subscribing do
what you can to help this thing grow but
let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow what a lad and i have a massive
lad on for you guys today the city of
sydney will be breathing a lot easier
this week after this star player has
recently signed with the waratahs for
another two more years massive news out
of sydney but before he was a super
rugby star he was a beast in the uk
premiership for firstly saracens but
even more so for london irish and now
that he's back in australia i promise
you it will not be long till we see him
in the gold jersey he's a hell of a
player and a hell of a lad it is the
great dave piriki welcome mate thanks
mate what an absolute privilege it is to
be on this massive podcast of yours i've
seen you from the very bottom to now the
top it's incredible to see mate and
great to have you on to boost my aussie
listeners but like i said in the intro
um huge news out of sydney would have
been front page all over the sydney
herald and stuff over there
was it an easy decision for you yeah um
actually have been like pretty quickly
to be fair um
and yeah it was it was easy for me like
it was um we were sort of looking well
as you do like
in contract negotiations i'm pretty open
to anything um just want to see like
what's out there
um obviously i've got an english
passport so um there were a couple of
little sniffs over there as well just
heading back but
because it happened so quickly here and
like essentially what i
like the whole reason i came back
as soon as they said they were keen i
was pretty much like yep just make it
happen um and get it done because
obviously like the worst thing
i hate is um things that i i'm not like
sort of the type of player that go oh no
no wait and keep playing i'm like i want
it done in my own brain you know i wanna
i want that security so um
yeah as soon as that happened i was like
to my agent please just if you can just
wrap this up quickly then i can just
sort of concentrate on footy
and uh especially this year like we're
actually obviously doing a little bit
better than last year so it makes it
better yeah mate nice and how have you
found it obviously the return to super
rugby have you found playing it's very
very different to uh obviously i had
like a little bit different journey i
sort of obviously went to the uk early
whereas a lot of people sort of go at
the end of their careers so i got to the
benefit of seeing
just the way it's run and obviously we
had sort of george skivington as our
forwards coach so he was probably um
most beneficial for me and sort of nick
kennedy as well
um they'll just like line out more scrum
nauseous so
i sort of developed
learning from them and then you sort of
come back to australia where
the priority is attack yeah so
um there were like a lot of things uh at
the club so that we just needed to
i guess just work on and and see if we
can incorporate some of that style into
into here set piece wise uh but it's
just like they just think about the game
completely differently obviously over
there
there's four months of the year where
you've literally just got to
rely on set piece and maul whereas here
you can pretty much just like
attack every single round and and set
pieces sort of an afterthought and then
i guess athletically wise i reckon you
actually get some probably some smarter
iq
players in the uk but that aren't
naturally gifted whereas here you get
the naturally gifted athletic players
that are just freaks of nature on the
field
um and that's probably why you see
like a lot of the kiwi or aussie players
that go over to the uk they normally
make their way into the starting side
just because in training you're like
whole holy [ __ ] they've got x factor
it's not the normal sort of english
player that uh you know they've grinded
their way through and they're big they
love the gym here it's like
we know how to play footy we know how to
like play what's in front of us and and
teams over there like absolutely love
that stuff as well case in point wow
i just remember you rocking up the irish
and then being like jimmy just plays
what's in front obviously when we lost
20 in a row they sort of reassessed
everyone in the squad
playing too much in front
well that's why like obviously you've
had mike coleman on previously he was
like
i think they probably wanted a little x
factor but they realized that he was
just
an absolute grinder
but obviously yeah he they loved him
there as well but yeah in short that's
what i'm sort of finding that speaking
about that the age difference between
the two comps is pretty significant hey
like the super rugby at the moment seems
like a really young competition and yeah
like you probably were one of the
youngest over in the uk premiership you
come back here you're probably one of
the oldest it's offensive man like i was
obviously one of the youngest in the in
the pack at irish and then i come back
here and you're getting called old bull
or
uncle or something you know
like i'm still young
i'm 29 but then when you're like my lou
said prop angus bell is 21 years old
like yeah um yeah it's very different
so yeah the age gap is massive but also
in the year that i sort of left
uh to go overseas was the year that
probably super rugby in age everyone
sort of left as well so the average age
probably went from like you know high
20s 30 to
back then and rebuilt and that's
probably the whole
story of australian rugby the last
couple years is that we're building
towards the world cup or
and that the players that are coming
through together as 21 22 year olds will
have sort of three or four years
playing with each other which is quite
good and i guess you can sort of see it
in the tiles this year from how we were
last year you know they're so young and
they got so much to learn but all they
need is sort of the right person at the
helm
and a couple years together just to
understand each other and i i think
that's probably why we've definitely
been better this year than last year you
just
sort of get those combinations you know
and they they don't brush
people here as easily as the uk they're
not sort of like a mercenary
type club they're very much like we
stick it together and see how they go
for a couple years mate and you've been
a huge impact on that waratahs side as
well
and it's been awesome seeing you out
there being able to play consistent
footy obviously a big part of your
career has been um i guess dampened by
injury plenty of injuries the way you
play how have you found it being able to
strength back-to-back games together
yeah
i'm loving it like obviously
pretty much played a full season um
last year as well and then like
obviously my calf pretty much exploded
and i got up and obviously the first
thing i thought of is like this is just
this is not going to be a good one
obviously i've had like enough sort of
like little tweaks to realize and i just
ended up being out for like eight months
it was obviously like a little bit
rattling because i pretty much missed
all the preseason then came straight
back in you got a new coach and i think
the worst thing is like when you're
injured with a new coach because you
can't no matter what you've done in your
career you've still got to start from
scratch with a new coach and obviously
he was over
in the us as well so i just wanted to
sort of show them what i could do so
anyway we got into trials and um
got through and then just i guess sort
of just been uh well touchwood going
well
this year so far with my body body feels
pretty good
and yeah i'm loving it like obviously
the more games the merrier it's very
different to
the uk where you you're backing up as
you know up you probably got like 25 30
games in that one year um with no rest
whereas here you sort of been asked to
play like 15-ish games um even though it
is like you know your body's pretty sore
after it because it's a lot quicker
um yeah it's good mate it's going well
and you've you're on the frame for
australia i think you've been into a few
camps
um have you have you found that yeah
that's unreal um obviously i was sort of
on the radar last year and then my calf
exploded
so i don't blame them for just you know
putting me in the back seat um i just
had to obviously get my body right that
was probably the main thing
and then uh
got included sort of in this three-day
camp recently which was sort of
more of a sort of admin and uh
sort of understanding team culture type
thing that didn't sort of train us hard
or anything which is um good because
obviously we're mid-season it was just
sort of like just get together
um understand where we're going because
i think you know we finished super rugby
and then they'll re-pick a squad for the
england series and there's only a short
amount of period between that time so
it's not like a massive training camp so
the more they can sort of meet
and um each week sort of send you
through your work ons or you know things
that
you're doing well
is good so i guess the best thing that
they do is they just keep you in the
loop they're ongoing so you super
perform they don't just sort of put you
in a camp and then leave you be they
just continuously talk to you
um and you can they're pretty open as
well you can ask
any questions you want um
about i guess what's going to put you in
the best sort of frame to be there
speaking about australia
obviously dave rennie's come in um have
you found working with him what's he
been like yeah he's pretty intense to be
fair um
and and pretty direct he's he tells you
exactly what he thinks um
which is the best
in my opinion obviously
it's a little bit different with younger
players you might have to sort of like
be a bit nicer you know what the crack
is just like around sort of even team
selection stuff i use that as an example
you can't pretty much go tell a 20 year
old their [ __ ] whereas
if you're
coming on 30 you can go and be like man
you had a [ __ ] game so i'm just gonna
and you you like appreciate the honesty
yeah yeah i think he's like that
regardless so he just tells you how it
is he's where he's where he stands
and i've i've just loved like i guess
the ocd and me just how organized
everything is um everything sort of has
a
everything's planned really well towards
something so obviously they're planning
towards this england series
everything in that three-day camp was
just perfect leading into that this is
what this is why we're doing what we're
doing
we're not just
putting up clips of england this is why
this is why we're gonna
um go well against them this is
the threats that they face and how do we
deal with it so everything's very very
detail-driven um so i was like pretty
impressed it's refreshing as well
because he's
had a lot of footy overseas in the uk so
he values a lot of that stuff as well
which is which is great so does he have
much of a influence on any of the super
rugby teams because obviously the
there's been big growth in the
australian super rugby teams uh this
season has he had much of an influence
on that or is that um sort of what you
just mentioned at the start about the
teams being together more
yeah so they um
in the uk when boys made england
obviously at irish there wasn't that
many people but i still know obviously
what it was like at saracens yeah you
never saw
any of the coaches like hanging around
the club or coming in for meetings but
with the wallabies
a lot of the coaches are pretty um you
know they've got direct contact with the
clubs because there's so many small
clubs
they can afford to just travel around
australia and do that so um occasionally
they're in i think sort of petrus
duplicity he's probably been um
in the most but you definitely see them
every every couple weeks they're coming
in
not only are they sort of checking up on
the players they're checking up on um
they're just going having meetings with
the coaches and um especially for our
coach
um he sort of picks dave rennie's brain
a lot which she's said outwardly in
media
um but example is sort of dave was
hanging around training
i think it was a week before like last
week or the week before and um you know
was just popping up to a couple of
players and asking them you know what
they're working on you know are things
called sort of winners blocks so it's
the end of training
things to work on so mate you that's why
you just had to
change him you barely had anything you
need to work on um whereas i'd be out
there for three hours just doing
everything mine was my hip i had to get
off the field
yeah fair enough
i remember you going out for like extra
kicking sessions and then coming and
going
um
so i guess using that as an example he
just constantly keeping on top of things
he here's what you need to do and what
are you actually doing do you actually
understand what your weakness is
so he's making that sort of direct
contact with you as well it's not just a
you know an easy text message he's
actually making the effort to come to
the club yeah to check in that you
actually are doing the things that
you're doing because i guess that's the
that's the biggest fear for those types
of coaches is that you you all meet up
at this in this
camp you tell them what they want to
hear and then you don't go do it um so
they're just constantly keeping you on
your toes i'm here like where
are you doing it made exciting times for
australia rugby but you did mention your
ocd um briefly in that last bit but
something i do want to touch on because
you are incredibly ocd incredibly
structured in your week and in your days
um when did you when did you start
having that
i reckon um i guess like i never went to
like a big school in sydney in terms of
rugby um so i had a couple like shitty
injuries um coming through school didn't
sort of make any of the rep teams so um
yeah it came from like predominantly it
was like a skiing school really
which obviously
um i i came out of school like 121 kilos
so i was massive um
i was playing loose head prop and
throwing
i was still pretty ocd like before games
and that i've like always cleaned my
room this is when i was living back at
home um so i think it started growing
but then
went to uni and sort of learned about
nutrition and then from then on
the process of that where
you know you're prepping meals and uh
and getting yourself right for training
i think something just clicked that i
was like i actually love this
the structure of it ended up like losing
a heap of weight and then working my way
into manly and then from then i think
just got worse and worse where
you know
game day the house had to be cleaned so
just gotta let's go
bigger and bigger and i remember
watching ben franks actually talk about
it and he's like he did like a
documentary he is the same thing you
just need to have like the house clean
but
i think mine sort of went onwards to
there into like my entire life not just
pre-game um i love
i think i've always said to my my wife
um
if i wasn't playing rugby you know i'd
probably be a military man just for how
like structured i like everything yeah i
think i'm just a man of mana routine
mana structure and i think it works
really well especially
as a professional footy player you need
to be
organized i'm not the type of bloke that
can just sort of get away with
airy fairy is what it is i need to have
everything sort of like planned out
organized i think that's just what works
for me so how does your week work do you
sit down at the start of the week and
plan your whole week or what's it look
like it's a little bit different like
with short turnarounds but um
in terms of food stuff like a lot of
clubs like provide meals but
i i just have always done it sort of my
way just sort of like do a big shop sort
of sunday and wednesday like the day so
i sort of like plan out the half weeks
yeah so on sunday like at some stage
i'll plan out the next couple of days
see what i need to do at the moment like
i was coming off um
had a bit of a
injury
had like an infected abscess which threw
me off for about three or four weeks
so i've just been building back up from
then really like it i lost like a bit of
weight after it was horrendous so in
like a good phase right now where you
know try and plan out especially my
training
monday tuesday
as like massive days and then um
taper towards the game
at the end of the week
so it definitely like chills out towards
the game because i want to feel fresh
but
making sure
when i'm knackered on monday tuesday
that i get
especially my gym stuff done because
i don't need to do sort of extra fitness
stuff because the training for
at the waratahs and in super rugby in
general is a lot more like running based
it's funny because
in the uk they would prioritize
the weights before the running sessions
they'd always say
no we want you to maximize your
weights
and then running sort of like an
afterthought training is enough thought
as you probably know
whereas here it's like no we don't want
you to jeopardize
getting a tweak or something in the
running session by doing weights so they
swapped it round so your sessions were
more important luckily this year we've
gotten
a blog called nick lumley who's uh come
from edinburgh
who is the trainer thought no we're
maximizing weights and again could be
the contributing factor to why we're
like doing better this year as well but
for me that's beautiful because five
years i spent
prioritizing that stuff and then having
the field session as you're holding on
and you know you're just holding on and
getting through it whereas
you know it sort of changed which i i
didn't necessarily like because you're
dropping weight you're getting weak um
and it's hard to get sessions in because
you're coming off doing six k's or
whatever in a session you absolutely um
rooted
so he's been like a massive injection
for us this year
which is uh which is really good for us
i think and like especially some of the
young kids they don't know
how much effort
other teams put into the gym to get to
where they need to be like i just
i can see both sides i know
a 21 year old in the uk
some of them don't even train sort of
half the week so that they can keep
weight on they smash the gym
um
put on all this size and then when
they're sort of like 23 24 that's when
they start
kicking on because they're physically
able to
you know play that high level
game physically
whereas here
it's pretty savage if they'll flogging
on flogging and floggia i'll just
speaking generally in terms of australia
vlogging on the field and then come up
to you and go mate you've you light like
we can't play you
well
oh and then
you know they'll struggle to put weight
on for a year or two and then they'll go
maybe see you later and they'll start
their life after rugby
ah so yeah it's pretty sad really savage
well it's interesting hearing the um
comparison between the two
um hemispheres yeah yeah it's like there
are obviously like massive differences
um but i think it is like aligning the
more interesting thing as well was how
keen
the uk clubs were of
australia when i was there they were
always
asking and then they actively try and
get aussie new zealand coaches over
um as you know like with irish they they
had tom coventry now they've got les
pierce
um
saracen sort of had dan vickers which
was he's a kicking coach from australia
so they're just always and they always
have these visits as well
from uk to australia or vice versa they
just constantly checking each other out
our forwards coach now paulie
um i actually met him in the i
met him in the change room at irish
because he came over to um watch and
observe and he went to sarri's as well
and he sort of uses some of this stuff
especially around meetings or
presentations
at the tires now but it's funny that
this year he took over and i sent him a
message i was like mate
who would have thought when i was
meeting you in the change room at irish
that you'd now be obviously my ford's
coach it was it was a funny moment yeah
well that is the crazy thing about rugby
this is such a small community you'll
you'll meet someone in some place and
then a couple years later you'll find
them other side of the world you'll be
being coached by them again pretty much
like your example yeah
i guess um
probably one of the best things i um
learn i reckon
was from some of the older players that
you know obviously yourself brennan
mckibben when i was coming through young
was just
try not to burn any bridges just
keep everything alive
and uh
i think that's like
worked for me in australia because uh
you know if that all they do is they
reference checks so sometimes if they
want to sign a player they just send a
message to a mate and go how's
dave go or how's jimmy go yeah and
they'll go oh
what a lad in your case um
and it all if you've burnt one bridge
it'll it'll be that bridge that comes
back and and they'll go oh mate we
actually got some negative about you um
so i always just try and keep everything
alive and
stay in touch with everyone not so much
on the way of like it'll benefit me in
the future but more just
you meet a lot of lads along the way
that you want to keep in touch with and
um and rugby is that like community
where everyone sort of sticks together
yeah 100 well i got all my contracts
from players or coaches that i already
knew like clarky got me over to london
irish over i got me to japan all these
people i just met previously and um for
some reason they they liked me and got
me over to that gig so i know a lot of
people put a lot of emphasis on agents
and stuff but for me it was always the
context 100
my funny story was um
i was actually sitting on the bench for
saracens we were playing london irish
and i was i think i was 24th man or
something and um i got approached by a
guy called grant dory and um he's
involved with like tonga rugby and he
was there um one of their coaches for
irish and he comes up to me and goes
dave
and i was like hey mate how are you and
he goes how are you grant dory um
mate actually um i actually used to
watch you um
when you were playing for manly
when i was with the blues like how are
you i was like oh we cracked on a
conversation all that and then he goes
man what are you doing next year just
out of the blue and i go oh you know
just working through some stuff here
sorry
what are you thinking he goes oh like
give me a number and um we'll have a
yarn
so again my number i'm fully kitted in
sarri's gear anyway no one's around us
or anything so he's come up to me and
then anyway walks off he's like yeah
i'll chat to you and then um
i met up with him like sort of two weeks
later and he told me that
after that interaction
irish got a call from sarri's pretty
much saying stay the [ __ ] away from our
players oh true
um yeah so and then but from that little
minute conversation i then met with
irish and then um that was when i met
sort of coventry and um grand dorian got
the contract so i'm lucky you sort of
like had the nuts to come up and have a
conversation but
little things like that he was watching
me back in australia
play for a club team
and then just a little one minute
interaction just got it started
and then even coming back to australia
because um i i was sort of when i was at
irish
kind of negotiating coming back to
australia i was about to
sign uh like a contract in the uk
and then obviously um
rugby australia like got in contact and
i said mate like
i really appreciate what's going on here
but i'm not gonna jeopardize like a
contract because you know if you're
gonna be slow
and was pretty honest with that anyway
because they didn't have enough time the
australian teams to sort of do their due
diligence and research sort of how i
played they were i was getting messages
from all my mates with like little
snippets of
people from rugby australia and even the
club teams asking how i am
yeah and obviously they're they're
messaging sort of my best mates so my
best mates are going mate
incredible like world beat up
little old days just sitting there
getting these messages being like mate
thank you so much but um it's i was just
like it's so good that i'm made to these
people at the moment because it's and
then from that it happened quite quickly
but obviously they they did a little bit
more research than just sending a text
but
yeah i agree with you in every pretty
much in every contract
um that's come into play massively
it is it's crazy but you did mention
about your
earlier days in australia so we will go
back to how it all started for you i
thought i knew a little bit about your
journey but turns out i didn't know too
much
um up until saracens so give us a
rundown up until there
yeah like obviously i didn't go to a
rugby school um sort of made my way
playing sort of a second division at
school and then had an injury
ended up i think i made
new south wales shadow squad as a lucid
prop which is
just one of the states in australia i
think i was the second person ever from
school to make anything above
anything in new south wales um so
they found my little name i didn't even
know i just got sent they found my name
in a newspaper that i was like the
reserve for the reserve for the reserve
so they were like loving it they were
like this is incredible
anyway nothing came with that i was like
121 kilos um as i said
and uh went into colts which is under
20s for for manly
played through there ended up captaining
like first colts whatever which is like
your 20 side for manly
still heavily overweight i just
obviously um
you know was bigger than a lot of kids
so made it easier for me still playing
prop still playing um loose head prop
but throwing but the throwing was just
horrendous um it's like hard to look
back on that anyway when you transition
from colts to grade
um this is over 20s you start playing
against men so i think something just
clicked then
i was always obsessed with jim but my
diet was horrendous you know i
spend three hours in the gym and then go
home and have like
the equivalent of a family size penang
chicken curry meals so obviously
and then i was wondering why i wasn't
losing weight but there you go
went to uni and then um
did it did some uh degrees and uh
and then learn about nutrition and from
then just something clicked ended up
losing like 20 kilos in like four months
i was just obsessed i had sort of like
this
big obsession with sort of fitness and
uh
and that kind of stuff got in really
good nick got help
from uh a couple of people as well that
were pretty knowledgeable and then went
into grade
ended up going into grade like 96 kilos
so at that point they were like
mate you're pretty small now to play
loose head
so
we're gonna move you into hooker luckily
i had a bloke on my right called tim
fair brother i'm not sure if you
remember him but yeah uh yeah he was at
the keynes and then went over played
quinn's and he was incredible for me
because you know he taught me a lot as
hooker like and this was back in the
days of crouch by and engage or whatever
it was um yeah so my neck still in bits
from that but he was just incredible
because he was just an older guy and i
was so young and so raw
uh so he helped me along and then each
year i just played manly did well my
first year
uh second year just built on some some
weight like just learnt how to train
properly and just was just building and
i had just this long-term sort of
three-year goal going back to the
structured thing
i was like i want to try get to sort of
this 103 kilos which you know looking
back is still pretty light now for super
rugby
anyway
played grade and then um had a really
good year one year and um
got a call from michael checker who was
then head coach for the tiles he's like
might come on in for this thing called
um a transitional contract which is
essentially the transitioning you from
club
to super rugby and they you know they
it's you know they give you petrol money
but they flog you so i was doing that i
was working um two jobs how old were you
i was 20 i think i was 20 at this stage
yeah 20 21
um so i was going to uni
doing full-time training guitars and
working two jobs but that's just the
standard thing you do anyway when you're
young like it was good it filled my time
i liked it um
did transitional year with them
learn i probably learnt the most of the
x player the x players now but the
current players in the system you know i
went in the front row was ben robinson
to typhoo plotter now and so kopi kappu
sakobi where i just played on the
weekend which was quite funny
so i would just i was a sponge i picked
everything i picked their brains so much
about everything i was just like a
proper nause about rugby
and just listening they also had mario
ledezma as a scrum coach who we didn't
really
click person because i was just a shy
sort of kid i kept my head down whereas
nowadays
you get young kids coming to supreme
they're very loud it was very different
back then you were head down if you
spoke you'd get put in the line or if
they didn't put you in a line verbally
they'd wait till you're on the training
field and then absolutely [ __ ] you up um
so i had those lads like had cliffy palu
telling me about his footwork and i was
like [ __ ] hell this is
incredible you look at the tarz team
back then it was essentially the
wallabies forward pack so really good
for me anyway
was like fourth string hooker because my
set piece was just
you know i was just working on as my
first year in super rugby it was
pretty [ __ ] house my round the field
game is pretty good though i reckon that
was my sort of point of difference but
if i i understand why i never played
um completely understand anyway
one game
two of the hookers one got concussed
someone got a red card
and then next week they'll fly into
south africa
so i'm sitting there fourth string
obviously the third string is the shoe
in fourth string they haven't called me
i think we leave on monday or something
i haven't got a call till like 9 p.m
sunday so they must have really gone
through their options before me
seeing if any of the loose head props
could maybe throw a dart
anyway they ended up calling me so i was
on the next flight over to um
south africa on a two-week trip
unluckily he didn't get like the best
ones got johannesburg against the lions
um
i didn't get on we lost by i think it
was like yeah we had a pretty big loss
set piece got annihilated that game
didn't get on so i was like okay anyway
we go to bloomfintene the next um
week we're up by 50.
10 minutes left so i'm like
like surely
like this is the one
so anyway ben robinson's on the bench
and he's he goes dave like get up like
start
warming up show me keane
so i'm i am [ __ ] busting i'm doing
malcolm's on the sideline essentially
like wind sprints just like showing them
like i'm keen ready to go we're up by
50. there's like four minutes left
i'm having a workout i'm absolutely
[ __ ] by the time i get on luckily they
got dave get on i had like
a three minute stint went one from one
in the line-outs i'd spent
the whole 14-hour plane ride learning
every single line out
um and then get one easy little default
lineup which is great hit that and then
i don't know didn't obviously i can't
really remember much else but it was
just an awesome achievement because i'd
sort of dedicated five years
prior to that moment you know i didn't
drink
i was i was just very very committed um
you know i never went out i was always
doing extras stuff i just worked my ass
off to try and get to that point
as a lot of my close friends know
like the sort of the sacrifices i made
um
anyway come back i'm uh lying on my
then girlfriend's couch jet lagged this
[ __ ] because obviously i haven't really
like traveled to south africa before
yeah get a message through from my agent
saying mate um
saracens are keen
on a four-month deal for you as world
cup cover because they were losing skull
brits and jamie george so they thought
they'd replace them with dave frackie
mate it must have been a good three
minutes oh it was incredible maybe they
just
no because um i think their benefit
going over there there i spoke with paul
gustar who actually got me over there
and he said pretty much it was between
you and two other hookers
the reason you got it was you got an
english passport so i didn't i never
really knew how handy that would be
so i go yup kane obviously tarz you know
they they didn't want to borrow me or
anything which it was pretty bad how it
ended
that to be honest like i didn't get much
comms when i left about sort of my work
on something i still sort of remember to
this day
so i went over to the uk
you know with some fire in the belly to
sort of like
have this longer term goal of like
coming back and and sort of proving them
wrong that they sort of let me go
went to saracens it was completely
different mate like shani my wife now
was like i'll just come and travel i
won't interfere because she obviously
understood that the next four months
she's going to be like massive in terms
of my career
i'll just come live with you i'll use
your
players house as a base and i'll just go
travel so i was like awesome because not
only did i have her over there with me
but also she understood and this was
like her first year she'd never been
understood like what the rugby career
was about where you know it's it's
essentially [ __ ]
for what it's pretty bad for your
partners you know um the sacrifices you
make as you obviously know
so in that four months they've obviously
come over and gone mate like we know
what you can do around the field the
opportunities here for you
to
stay here long term but what we need you
to do is you need to work on your set
piece
by that stage
towards the end of the waratahs i
actually started to click about
scrummaging i just
something clicked i just understood it
understood like what i needed to do it
was the throwing that was horrendous i
was self-taught
as a lot of young hookers are you just
pick up a ball and you go that feels
good i'm gonna throw it there wasn't any
specialty coaches or anyone that like
technically broke down
my throws so pretty much
land at salaries they were incredible
their sort of motto was we'll worry
about everything off the field so you
can worry about everything on the field
that was down to everything you know
they had a podiatrist come in
on days off to
fix your toenails up they
put your kids in a crash um
you'd come off the field of a fitness
session you'd have like a
berry coconut juice to rehydrate like it
was just incredible mate like
and something i wasn't used to
so when your stuff's laid out
ready to go every day you just chuck it
back in the laundry i was like mate do i
need to go back and clean this and
they're like no mate we we do that for
you
but it's so you can perform and they go
out and the training sessions would be
so intense
the level of coaching was
amazing like not one coach was out of
place there they all knew exactly what
the go was their presentation with of
how they were doing stuff was awesome so
i was just you know i had all the old
guys
come up to me be like matt i'll take you
out for coffee i'll take you out for a
meal like skulk brits and
ernie jaber
um neil decock these
50 cap spring box
whatever coming in they won't have a
coffee with me i got no life experience
i don't know how to even speak to these
guys
um on the air like i ended up being
really good mates with um juan figalos
an argentinian tie dad who was getting
me around every fortnight to have a
barbecue at his it was just completely
what i wasn't used to everyone was a lad
anyway so back into the rugby stuff
they they put there was this blog called
simon harding he worked for the rfu so
he's essentially a throwing coach so he
goes around to every english club
and works with the players that are
english qualified
it's their way of like that bigger
picture of uh developing sort of hookers
to be able to throw i'm english
qualified so he goes we meet he helps me
out he goes
i'm sorry mate like
you are [ __ ] at throwing um
i was like ferret this is what i want to
hear it hurts but this is what i want to
hear this because this is more than i
ever got back home you know it was just
keep repping whatever what's actually
wrong with my throw and he goes this is
what's wrong your hands i don't
understand like what are you doing with
your hands
i don't know and anyway he gets the ball
and he goes this is yeah wow i don't
know
he goes this is how you're going to
throw
he gets the ball he literally places my
hand on places my hand on and he goes
we're just going to do this for the next
two months
and so it broke down every step so he
literally got
these boxing gloves and put them in
front of my eyes
and i would like do that into the boxing
gloves
to to do follow-through
he then the next step was your hands are
good that's automatic i'm gonna
come in every week and i'm gonna stick a
broomstick
here
and if you hit the broomstick the
session's done so if i'd drop my chest
and hit the broomstick i didn't miss an
opportunity to work with him so i'm like
it obviously forces you to keep the
chest high yeah he broke down every
little thing so i get in
and the best thing was that saracens
come up to me and they go
the head coach mark macaulay goes mate i
know
it's not going to be pretty
but what we want to see
is that you've got the motivation and
the persistence to keep doing it and to
keep
practicing
you know if you did one session with
your throwing coach and then you didn't
practice all week like
we're not i'm not gonna keep you here
like this is just gonna be the way it is
so i go mate like you don't need to tell
me like
i was the most obviously like keen to to
learn because i didn't want to i wanted
to learn how to hit a mark instead of
[ __ ] you know
not worry about where he's going anyway
so we play this um
trial game first trial game comes up
and around i probably had one of the
best games like i've ever had
but i look back to the throwing and it
was like [ __ ] end over end like i was
hitting people in the stomach
it was not good because i was obviously
learning how to do it but the fact that
around the field i played so well
um
ended up like i broke my hand so i
cracked on playing with a broken hand
and i had a head knock
so i'm like sitting there after the game
going to the hospital and they're like
my i'm getting calls from like the bloke
who brought me open like mate you played
so well we're so impressed like we're
gonna look to keep you on for the rest
of the year
so i was like great i bought myself some
more time anyway that all healed i came
back and um just started to like i think
that was one game we played in france or
i i threw like it was just one of those
games everything went right throwing
wise so they could obviously see that
the time i was putting in was paying off
i was still very inconsistent but i just
had one of those games that just
worked perfectly which
happened for you every single game
anyway
um
got on to it and then uh as the year
went on like just had like a couple of
niggly injuries you know like popped a
rib or you know tweaked a hammy or
something so didn't work out but if
anything it gave me sort of the time
just to like work a lot with simon the
throne codes just to continue banging it
out anyway ended up staying for the
whole year which was awesome like it was
one of the best times of my life and uh
had some incredible hookers in front of
me like sculptrits and obviously jamie
who helped me they had no reservations
in helping me
progress i picked their brain you know i
had like mock over and apollo
i would just ask him a lot of questions
and just be a proper nause do a lot of
review stuff and then got to the end of
it and that's when i had the
conversation with grant on the bench
because towards the end of that about
playing sort of like four or five games
to them in the prem
and was 24th man for like a fair bit of
them and then had the conversation with
grant and then so i went up to
sarri's and i was like mate i'm just
going to be because you guys have been
so good to me i'm just going to be
honest like if you guys want to have a
crap like i'm keen
but where where where are you taking me
here like because obviously you've got
these two or three hookers that are
incredible internationals i'm nowhere
near that
so
if i stay am i even gonna play because i
knew by that stage i was sort of 22 i
needed to just play and if i was gonna
throw [ __ ] i'd throw in [ __ ] and game
and and learn from that and he said
i think you you're smart enough to
realize like where you see it
so if irish offering you a two-year deal
with sort of the
the goal of making you for the first
choice then that's
then that's i think that's smart and the
fact that he sort of said
that looking for me
you know selfishly i could have gone oh
no we can definitely keep like a third
fourth stringer here as numbers he was
like no we want you to develop this is
the whole thing like they sort of see it
as a win for them that they're able to
bring someone over and then kick on to
another club which is just like tells
you a lot about the club anyway so sign
with irish and then
had david pace
as their first choice there which was
again i've gone from having these two
quality hookers to another quality
hooker who
probably
didn't teach me so much technically
about scrummaging or lineup but probably
just the toughness side of it
that after games you'd see him pretty
much wheelchair into the physio room
with brian o'leary the physio there
and then go out on the weekend and be a
machine you know he was his body was
hanging on by a thread it was just
incredible to watch and and um we had
like a mutual respect for each other
because
i just kept my head down continued to
work i wasn't that guy that was you know
coming out and being a hero in training
but in games i'd obviously try and
always put my body on the line and
in those probably two years continued to
work and then um sort of played sort of
those pretty much two years off the
bench and uh obviously missed out on
coventry and um
and dory because as i signed with them
we got relegated and they got sacked
so we got new coaches in in the bottom
league is obviously when you came as
well the championship what a grind
and uh ben frankson that
was in there so you know i got some
experienced players and if looking back
on it it was actually really good for me
because it was another year to develop
in a you know less competitive league
even though it's still very good there
were still some games that you're like
okay
like this is this this is 60 nil so you
know it took a bit of the pressure off
and then the the following year the
second year was when i sort of like
started to kick on and
and play well and my throwing was coming
on and then um iris saw that and under
nick kennedy and um skivs and that they
sort of kept me there for another two
years and that two years was the two
years that i
really started to to kick on
set piece wise and just sort of like
play just continue to play and develop
and kendo was like mate
we we expect big things from you um
you're going to be transitioning now
into sort of like our first choice
hookah
because um pacey's like going to retire
oh he's going to sort of like take a
backward step
i was like awesome this is like
everything's sort of trending towards
this and then
had a good really good two years and
then um you obviously you'd left by then
um relegation so the story was obviously
we got relegated
we relegated promoted and then won the
first game against quinn's in front of
60 000 and a double head so we're like
we are here we go this is our year we've
done it we've done the hard yards and
then
oh i'm what 16 straight we lost um
oh my god
uh and then that's when the coaches sort
of got
came back in we got brennan venture in
and i remember there was like
it was like round eight there's 24
rounds
and he's come into a meeting and he's
gone lads
we're relegated there's nothing we could
[ __ ] do about it there were like
eight games in you know we're like we're
not even last and i think and he's just
already foreseen that this team's gonna
be [ __ ]
we're relegated we're not we're not
going to be good so
at least we're going to have a [ __ ]
crack we can take some scalps along the
way so i remember he had like these hats
next to like the rounds on the wall that
like we took the
you know and then obviously went bit
downhill from there
every single game so we got relegated
again
mate that was it and then he and then
see you later
so came in essentially told us we're
[ __ ] we're going to get relegated he was
it was [ __ ] awesome working with him
though because
of the i actually really enjoyed him you
probably didn't because you know i
i enjoyed him as well i found him
awesome i thought he was a real smart
man and loved the way he thought about
the game he was really good
yeah and just good for us because we had
like some younger coaches coming in
and um
he just [ __ ] he just told you how it
was if you if you played [ __ ] he was
like mate you're not playing because
your [ __ ] and it's presentations oh
he he was someone who you you're always
nervous listening to him
yeah yeah i remember this
i remember
he was clearly wrong about this one fold
that led to a try
everyone knew it everyone knew but
no one said a word like no one says a
word
uh i think
okay yup you're right you're right
so anyway he left and we got relegated
again so went down to the champ and then
you'd left by then i knew again in the
second relegation yeah i left after that
yeah yeah so like a lot of people left
we got like a lot of new people in
and um
as a squad
we got half i think it was sort of like
halfway through that year we got new
coaches again
so this is now the third string of new
coaches
in three years so
which was tough you know um
a lot of the coaches stayed on like kids
give stayed on as four's coach which is
amazing for me because like i can't
speak highly enough of skivvs um
and the squad and then uh
you know we just built we just built we
came together
started to build like sort of
combinations really well we started to
understand sort of the coaching what
they wanted and then we got promoted
did well that year which was awesome and
then that year was when we really like
came together as so there was like sort
of five or six in the leaders group
and we said look
we're just getting new coach after new
coach like they come in it takes a good
four or five months for them to really
understand
the playing group or
where we're going wrong or what's wrong
with the culture
so we just
said [ __ ] this let's just do it
ourselves so we came together as a
playing group and and we just pretty
much
redesigned i know obviously you can't
you say you can't really like create
culture it's just got to naturally
happen but i think we did we put in
things to be more professional um we'd
heard so much about actually like the
crusaders leadership group that
they've got so much power that they can
essentially
go into their head coach and say mate
like this is what we think and head
coach is so open that he can he can just
take that on board we didn't have that
we had so the coaches ran everything the
players were like an afterthought so we
tried to
rebalance that narrative
um so we came we put in stuff like we
were like the professionalism is [ __ ]
here so
if you're if you're late to a physio or
you forget something
um there's gonna be a fine and the fine
is you throw
a dart
at the dartboard and every dart is uh
related to a um a
punishment yeah um so it's funny you see
these young lads up there [ __ ]
shaking and they miss the board and
there's a hundred quid fine so it's like
it not only got the boys around each
other because it's so [ __ ] funny it
also kept boys accountable because you'd
see them running to the physio rooms and
then other things would be like we had
no values
as a club
every club you go to you see stuff in
the gym
but we were like what can we as players
actually
create that people are going to buy into
so we did so much work on this stuff and
then we just obliterated the gym with
stuff
and the group was just awesome we were
meeting like once a week we were saying
what needs to be done and um we then
headed into the premiership just like
a different side and then that year you
know we actually got some gritty wins
and i'm not putting it down to like the
culture stuff but there's got to be an
element that like has helped the club
from where it was you get these new
players in you get a group of lads
together that we actually did like there
was no [ __ ] in there we all like
loved each other
we worked hard
um and we're all on the same page so we
just said like you know if we [ __ ] up
and we're on the same page we're happy
with that no worries like we'll just
have a crack at the next day and we
weren't going to beat those exeter
sarri's teams
because we weren't there yet but we we
ground them out i remember like we
played sarri's and pissing down rain and
we just
stayed in the fire stadium in the fight
we got so close
just mentally we were all switched on
and stayed and then we had like some
amazing wins that year
um and then covert hit and uh for me
like it was unfortunate because like i
wanted to see where the season went but
obviously by that stage
i was off contract so i was um
you know i was either staying at irish
for a long term deal or i was gonna
probably move to another club and then
out of nowhere you know i'm messaging my
um
agent saying is there anything doing in
australia before i sign this because
like it to be honest i don't really mind
like i
it's positives of both i either come
back and have a crack or i stay here and
i um
finish essentially finish my career here
because you know by that stage i would
have been sort of 27 or 28. anyway so he
said no there's nothing um
nothing doing that that you know they're
pretty disorganized at the moment um and
the how quickly the clubs in the uk were
coming out like it's just it doesn't
align right so guys fine
so i then start renegotiating you know
between these two clubs in the uk and um
get put on a deadline of two weeks to
you know give the the comms and on the i
think it was the 12th day my agent gets
in contact and says mate like hold don't
do anything um like rugby australia have
said they're keen because they're trying
to bring these players back home
and i go [ __ ] hell you're like you're
cutting it fine
but we just need a provincial club to be
keen so they were obviously reaching out
to the provincial clubs and um
got like two on board but
he wanted scott johnson wanted to have a
phone call with me before anything
happened
this was now the 13th night so
i pretty much needed to make the
decision the next day and i was like
adamant in my mind just the way i
operate i'm like
i'm not having anyone come in here and
[ __ ] this up for me um so if they if
they want to [ __ ] around or whatever and
do the whole contracting
you know back and forth thing i'm not
about it you either offer something or
i'm going to sign here that's just the
way i want to do it
anyway so 3am
have a conversation
with scott johnson and um obviously
went well like we probably spent 15 20
minutes talking about like the color of
the jersey
i was like this is different and um
[Laughter]
it just was a good dude i just had like
a natural conversation with him i wasn't
really asking about rugby stuff because
obviously he'd done his due diligence
and knowing what type of player i was i
just kind of wanted to know what he was
about because he was
sort of at the helm
and then you know the offer came through
the next day and um told my my wife
because i was trying to like keep it on
the wraps being like oh there's a little
bit of interest because i didn't want to
get her hopes up went up at like 3 30 or
4 in the morning and said oh by the way
like i just had a call
and it looks like we're probably going
she started she burst into tears because
it's been five years since over there
she was so keen to get home but at the
same time we built this amazing life
over there we loved it and she loved it
but it was a fact she could just you
know have a little bit of a break
because it'd been so long
and then yet um
signed with the tars spoke to rob penny
and then um
came back in
and um
in quarantine
so obviously covert hit and got back in
quarantine
they hooked me up with this like
gym it was incredible like they gave me
mats
cycling bike all this stuff anyway one
of the exercises was
now you gotta you gotta run on the spot
i'm like okay yep no worries um and
they're like yeah if you run on the spot
mate
you'll be ready to go
like you're gonna be ready to fly
so i'm running on the spot anyway
because you're so immobile in there i'm
like doing laps around quarantine like
with my headphones on listening to what
a lad in fact
um
and so i run on the spot and i feel my
calf tweak
and i'm like [ __ ] hell so i got a
week left i've called the medical and i
made my calf
something's doing and then what from i
was like
running on the spot
anyway get out of
get out of it and it like it's gotten
better which is good and they put me
through like a little flush run and then
they go mate like this round one
tomorrow so don't worry about that we'll
train you for a week and then get you
look to get you involved round three
so train and then um get named on the
bench round three first game and then we
go out for monday training everyone's
come up to me and congrats man like they
don't know me or anything like well done
this is awesome
and first drill i backpedal and i just
feel my calf tweak
oh i'm like [ __ ] hell like this is
this can't be happening anyway so that
rules me out and then the next week they
like
we run again on it re-tweak and then the
following week after that run again on
it re-tweak and then that they go mate
you you're done for the the seat so it's
just like i'm just there like is this a
[ __ ] nightmare like
i've obviously come back in my first
season i'm now just missing the season
because i've got a weak calf that's just
continuing to repair
shambles anyway
that season goes on we actually do quite
well and then um obviously make my way
back in and then in the in the following
year my calf's fine um the
ended up like actually getting a two
games in this rugby australia select
team where they played argentina because
obviously
they'd sort of brought back they wanted
to see what i was about so it was good
to actually just get on and be like i'm
fine my calves are fine now and then we
cracked on with the tars and then
eventually sort of started
i played pretty hefty minutes
and then um it was the second last game
against the highlanders away and um
i was in a scrum and um went to hook the
ball and the scrum collapsed at the same
time and my calf like i just felt like
my calf explode that's true so i'm like
feeling down my calf and i'm like
nothing's switching on so i'm like oh
[ __ ] what have i done here
so i'm obviously like pretty upset
because i know like i've done something
horrendous so come off
you know by that stage i'd already made
like a sort of wallaby camp and uh the
team was getting picked the next week
for all the travel stuff so
in my mind i was like i'm in for a shot
at it but this is gonna [ __ ] me up so
i didn't know how severe it was and then
you know did scans and and um they were
like mate
essentially we've never seen this um
the physios that i was dealing with had
never seen this thing it's called
aponeurosis which is essentially you got
your two calves your gastrocnemius i'd
separated those calves from each other
so they're like we don't you can't
surgically operate on this because it's
connective tissue
um so you're just gonna have to wait and
so we waited i was like mate i was at
the pool at like 8 p.m clovelly every
clovelly is just a speech around the
corner for me all the sydney siders
would know it the the millions that lift
listening
i was down there like night just trying
to get this fluid out my calf was like
the size of my quad essentially it was
just so much fluid from like just this
trauma it's a big car yeah oh yeah and
um yeah
anyway
got a couple like weeks months down the
track and it just wasn't
improving i couldn't i could barely walk
um made i was like off feet for two
weeks pretty much not being able to walk
which is just horrendous by this stage
my missus was
um in the early stage of her pregnancy
so again going back to how hard it is
for partners
i was on the couch while she was
battling through her first trimester
which was so difficult for me the
blessing was that i missed all that
stuff so i could be there for
you know the start and that journey
which was amazing um
anyway we went and got scans because i'm
like this is just not working i need to
do more here so i was in contact with
like my irish physios being like made
have you ever heard of this what can i
do
just anyone i could contact to like get
their sort of
head around
it i was like sort of sending scans off
like reports
um and then they go oh have you tried um
aspirating it which is essentially they
just stick a needle in and get all the
fluid out so i was like yeah whatever
like let's try that so i went in sort of
spoke to the physios like can we just
try this
next day booked me in took it out after
that probably got like 50
motion back
i could feel it in the pool like went
straight to the pool after just
magically got rid of all the blood they
picked they took about eight mil of
blood i remember seeing this tube of
just blood that was just stuck in this
pocket at this stage it's like a couple
months down the track you know i'm
getting sort of the wallabies guys
coming in checking up on me anyway it
actually starts to progress but as you
know
with calves if you're off your car for
so long your achilles and starts to
flare up so whilst my calf was healing
even though it was weak my achilles then
fled up
so i got the wallabies um
physio coming in this is right before
the spring tour and he's like this is
just the test for you we're just going
to see how it is
i'm like okay that's fine and i was
telling my physios because i was
trying to push ahead of schedule i was
like mate can you just please let me
like just have a crack at this if i do
damage i'll i'll cop that i'll be the
one to be responsible for that but i
wanna i need to have a crack to see if
this is gonna work
anyway get run
um by the physio and i was in [ __ ]
like agony in my keys you could
obviously see i was limping but i was
just like i'm just gonna do this i'm
just gonna have a crack
gets off he's like mate
like you know
like this is not right uh you need to
like just get this right now for next
season and obviously it's pretty
disappointing but i knew what the goal
was as well before so
anyway
weirdest story was
new coach comes in dc darren coleman and
he gets us doing these like hard yucca
sort of saturday morning sessions where
we just go off site you know you pick a
beach just old school like just love it
like it's good obviously you missed out
on like saturday off but it was for the
bigger picture of where we needed to be
because we had a horrendous season for
the tars so he's just rebuilding culture
anyway so like i couldn't do a lot of it
anyway though i got close and and they
um go oh you guys need to do this
session because this is what we built
this is what i love like and it's like a
surf boat kind of rowing stuff so you
like run out from the beach to this boat
meanwhile my car's still hanging on for
dear life anyway i just go [ __ ] it let's
just what's the worst that can happen
you know
looking back a lot of bad things could
happen but um
so do the session i'm running down the
sand into the water and it's that run
that they didn't account for that there
is actually a bit of movement
for my calf you know unstable ground
anyway so do the session is so good man
like the bonding we had like it was so
fun it was like five a.m in the morning
so like the sun's coming up beautiful
anyway the next day there's like three
or four of us oh sorry the monday three
or four of us that we were like mate
this up like my foot is flat up because
like we've just been running on sand
and i'm like [ __ ] like i should have
just said no i should have just because
they gave us the option to and i was
like
no no i want to do it and um i should
have just said no on monday i couldn't
train and then
tuesday didn't train had wednesday off
came in on thursday they're ready and
out of nowhere like my achilles pain
just vanished it was almost like it was
like this magic trick of running on sand
that switched this achilles on i don't
know why but from then
all the rehab i just flew through the
rehab um i got no achilles pain like my
strength was coming back and then
missed pretty much all the preseason but
would do these hard yakker sessions you
know you do boxing or whatever
and then a week before the season start
my
my wife gave birth to my my baby so i
missed a missed like a trial and then
just came back played one trial game for
match fitness and then um he was like
we think you're you've done enough like
sort of 40 50 minutes against fiji draw
which
you saw highlights of them against the
rebels the week before and they're
scoring 100 meter tries i've been out
for eight months i've done like a 30
minute game against club team so i'm
like yeah no i'm very keen very keen for
this even though i actually i was very
keen
i was just more like
how am i gonna get fit luckily i had the
snc go mate i'm gonna get you fit in two
weeks i'm gonna flog ya um
and then from then on just been
really i guess that lasted a really big
injury was probably one of my worst in
terms of like mentally and i'm like
quite mentally strong it just sort of
woke me up this year to be like what are
you like what are you not doing
that a used to do when you're fine or b
you could do more of now to put yourself
in the position to not break down when
it counts you know you're not playing
anywhere near the amount of games or
minutes that you played
in england so what what it what is it
that you're not doing and um
it made me reassess things about sort of
my recovery or food or training and just
um
yeah as the season's gone on i've just
been really like quite anal with the way
that i sort of like prepare and keep my
body even through like the newborn phase
with luka
just trying to do everything i can to
make sure that you're peaking in the
right
times um
whether or not that's helped or made a
difference i don't know but touchwood so
far like i've had
obviously a couple little niggles as you
do through a season but um
yeah we'll just we'll just see how it
goes really i can only just
continue to crack on so mate that is
essentially my rugby story
one of the great rugby stories you did
mention luca there how has he changed
your life
well it's
different like um
playing isn't it like
come back from monday tuesday big days
you're actually like pretty pumped to
get home to see what he's like like
he i get his grizzly period i take him
off shania's hand for his grizzly period
in the afternoon and i'm like holding on
for dear life
but i know obviously she spent the
entire day with him so i gotta like just
try and puck her up um
but it's just awesome i can't wait we
were pretty diligent in the first like
sort of three months of his life we're
uncovered so we just kept them away from
like a lot of people but now i think
he'll probably come out to the game this
weekend against the canes for the first
time so just being able to like take a
photo with him man it's just like it's
awesome and i'm not that type of guy
that was like very clucky for a kid you
know i was
just like whenever you're comfortable
we'll um
you know we'll do it and we'll just
back ourselves as parents and um
and we'll learn on the run
and it's just pretty difficult
especially the first stage like with
going away you think coming back to
brother you're not going to travel that
much we actually do you know you're like
you're a night here in canberra then
you're away for two nights in um
auckland or whatever and it's difficult
you know she's juggling out on our own
it's it's it's hard as a partner having
having a young child um
just the time away so i just make sure
like i can
try and support her as much as i can
when i'm home but it's it's awesome man
i'm like i'm loving it what a dad but
how structured are you um has he got a
super structured routine as well
this is like the um this is going to be
the topic of thing on this podcast isn't
it just how [ __ ] ocd weird i am um
you haven't even scratched the surface
either
ah
oh like you can't you can't like i i
always ask you i'm like what like
when's the sleep routine stuff started
because you don't like
newborns they sleep when they want like
not what they want but like you know as
he's gotten older
there's more and more like things you
start put in place
for him there's nothing right now
there's no there's a routine at night
he's sort of his bath bathtub that gets
him down which is awesome but up until
then shanice just a machine um
she's been amazing especially like with
the training load and he's coming down
to like pretty important time
waratah wise um so she she understands
like the start of the week is is
horrendous
like in terms of she's just she needs to
obviously just carry the team really and
um and then i try and just do as much as
i can to just like facilitate really but
no he um
i guess as he gets older he'll have a
bit more like structure but i'm not
going to force him if he wants to do it
if he can you know i'm not going to be a
pushy parent oh am i i don't know
but before luka you also had another
child i guess you would call it um your
little sausage dog frankie yeah hey
how's he going
he's going well he
he uh we had a little late night at the
vet the other night with his back but um
maybe he had a naughty insta following
um over in the uk but since then he
we've uh we brought him back from the uk
which was a shambles don't i don't ever
recommend anyone in your millions of
listeners listeners bring their dog back
from the uk it was pretty much a year
thing
but he's gone strong he is my first
child um i'm not embarrassed like a lot
of people will see this big
rugby player walking around getting the
morning coffee with a long-head sausage
dog and they go
i get a lot of comments about and i go
yep
nice you're judging me on my dog
um but yeah mates we've got a nice
little family going here
yeah and 11 000 followers is it legit or
did you pay for those i didn't pay it
used to be actually like i boasted about
this even though i never
uh never ran it it was like it used to
be 16 and i was actually contemplating
just changing like making it my profile
um because i only had a lot of like 60
followers or something you know like no
one gave a [ __ ] about my photos
um
changing it but genuinely like i reckon
there was probably 20
of um the followers were
actual people that liked slices dogs the
other were like oh my wife is like
posting photos of me in irish gear so
they're just rugby noises you know just
coming on and following this dog's
account so they can get access to like a
rugby player's life even though i'm like
you know yes
so yeah there was some strange there's
some strange humans that like make up
the majority i reckon of that insta
following but maybe you know we haven't
posted it for a while it's just i keep
it up there just for for last you know
it's a funny little conversation starter
when i meet someone new and they go on
my profile and see that it's like
linked to my dog it's just always funny
that you know
oh frankie absolutely
but uh what are the plans for you going
forward obviously um you've signed two
more years at the waratahs there's a big
world cup carrot um next year for you
is that the sort of goals yeah i think
um
as a player
for me i'm not like i'm not massively
financially driven that you have to you
know i'm like i don't want to do this i
want to go to japan or whatever you know
and cash in
if i'm trying to do something
like play footy or anything in my career
even my life after rugby stuff that i
want to do
i need to be like aspiring for that
top and even if you don't hit it the way
that i sort of operate i just need to
otherwise i just don't have the
motivation to
do the [ __ ] i do during the week you
know like i don't i wouldn't be bothered
to sort of like meal prep or prepare or
sacrifices with your partner or even
with you like my newborn son or
your body on a sunday um or the way the
surgeries you put your body through i
just wouldn't think it's worth it so for
me
it's always been the goal ever since i
left australia to come back like i
needed to go over there develop
in the areas i needed to work on and
then it was to come back and at least
have a crack
this is what my dream like essentially
like this is what i've worked a decade
of my career for it is to have a crack
but in in saying that i just have the
small steps you know like you're not
gonna i'm realistic or coaches aren't
gonna pick you if you're just cause you
want it like you you need to actually
perform and if you perform with the tars
things will happen doors will open
you'll act you'll at least have a
conversation about where you sit
so in that small sort of goal it's just
continue this year performing for my
team and i love the tarzan where we're
heading now i love everyone in the
organization
it's been it's been an awesome year and
a year that we will continue to to grow
throughout and that is the main reason i
am staying because i do see the
development you know we've got a lot of
exciting things happening we've got new
facilities and all this stuff that will
only help we've got people returning
and then if if the wallabies happens at
the end of the year you know my focus
shifts to that how can i perform the
best i can perform at that level in my
mind
i'll cross that bridge when i get to it
and then you know
world cup stuff that'll only happen if
you're performing wallabies that's not
gonna happen if you're
third or fourth string hooker there you
know you might get it looking to be a
training member but i don't want that
like that's not my goal um i've seen
that throughout my career where people
are happy getting paid
just to be a third or fourth stringer
but i i can't be about that i may as
well just go and not wake up not being
able to move my neck and but go get an
office job you know i just don't see the
point in it um yeah
so yeah i guess that's a bit of my sort
of motivations the next couple years i
guess i'm just
building continue to develop and if it
happens
then it happens and um you know i'll try
and do the best i can at any level i'm
playing
you mentioned money there and you are
one of the probably the least motivated
player i've met buy money you always
like you said you always it's always
about being the best and
where's the lack of interest on the
money side of things come from oh don't
get me wrong obviously you know if
they're offering you a bag of skittles
and a can of coke like you're gonna say
no thanks but um
i guess i'm pr i'm probably just like
confident that
if i can put my mind to something
i'll be okay so even sort of like life
after rugby stuff you know like if rugby
doesn't pan out in the next couple years
the way that i sort of envisioned then
i'll have a crack at
something else and i'm confident that
the work that i'll put into something
i'll reap the benefits and um you know
if that's financially then
so be it if that's the actually driving
towards something in life in terms of
like a
you know a journey through another
business um
then that's something that i always look
towards like i just i want to be
involved in something that's actually
got a purpose i think like
or got a goal to work towards i find
that
like the most intriguing thing i reckon
the most motivating thing you're
actually working towards
something as a team and so um which is
why i'm so excited about the waratah
stuff like again
this for me is like my
my long-term goal ever since i started
rugby so why would i
you know why would i say oh no i'm not
getting paid enough when 20 years down
the track you know i'm gonna look back
and be like you you should have just
[ __ ]
had a crack and and you could have done
something like with your career you
could have reached the pinnacle and what
like
50 grand or 100 grand like
stopped you from doing that um
i think i'll be probably like quite
embarrassed with myself if that's the
case
there's that case and then there's
people that are getting offered two
million a year
to go play in japan and that's
life-changing money you know you can
but i'm not i'm not at that stage you
know um i'm not that type of player that
well yeah
where you're sitting now even retired or
closer to that than me
but yeah so you know that i guess that's
my sort of train of thought with that
yeah i like it i like it it's a cool
mindset and you did mention a little bit
about life after 40 have you got
anything in particular you're thinking
you're going to go down yeah um i think
we've sort of like discussed in the past
like i was pretty proactive in the uk
that they're massive on their life after
rugby stuff so i ended up just doing um
diploma into the financial trading and
then um
um undertaking currently um it's called
like cfa which is to be to become like a
chartered financial analyst so um
oh like it's a lot it sounds nice but
it's a lot of atmosphere it's a hell of
a lot of work especially juggling
professional rugby so i'm struggling
with at the moment but
just making sure like i'm working
towards something and then i think sort
of the next like year or two now that
covers chilled out i'll start doing some
sort of work experience stuff
in that financial sector so again
if any of the millions are in that reach
out to me kane
i'm also like on the on the rupa rep
here so um
i'm also pretty like keen on lads
here
that aren't exposed to it to just do
something outside of footy and just
just trying to get a few things going
with that um because i know i've seen it
both hands i've seen people come out and
be um
incredible post rugby
or the other way where they finished and
they're like you know they're [ __ ]
they've got nothing
ready to go and um just like what it
does for your life as well like your
balance in your life
i think is because obviously i was so
narrow-minded with just rugby and then a
lot of things happened that
you know i started doing a lot of things
outside of footy that it actually helped
my rugby because i wouldn't go home and
dwell on things i just yeah you know it
it really helped me so um
yeah
i i'm i'm actually excited for like life
after we stuff but
at the moment i've got like a you know a
big two three years ahead to to achieve
something i've been working towards for
a decade and we'll see where that goes
no wonder you're not worried about um
the money side of things with rugby
you're trading making millions every
every single day no no no you just do
courses and then um and then too afraid
to dip your toe in so it's good
[Laughter]
oh but what a story and what a lad um as
always we have gone to our instagram for
some questions we have had a few come in
for you as always here we go ah first
one how are you always the best trainer
on a tuesday
i noticed this too actually
i'm definitely
um that's something i reckon once i hit
23 i stopped doing that it was more
survival mode on a tuesday really um
so that's that's definitely not me
okay next one can you please stop
sending me to overpriced sushi
i also experienced this with you as well
this is a common trend
as you know there's a couple things in
my life that i value very highly and
sushi's one of them so
anywhere i'm at i google best sushi near
me
i give a [ __ ] about price i just want
the best um
so yeah there's a funny story one of the
a cad lads
here asked me because obviously i found
out i'm not only a coffee fiend but a
sushi theme they asked me oh yeah
where'd he go i got this incredible
place just here so that all three of
them go
sit down
and they go they're normal you know
they're normally used to like these
dollar rolls or whatever they sit down
it's like 15 for this massive like set
so they all go over skull the glasses of
water and walk out
oh classic i think you sent me to a few
of those in london too
okay next one ask him why he's never
been to a social in his life
um
i'm very much like a like a time and
like it's the right time you know like
if we got a game
i can't
mentally back up from big nights so if
we're going out for a couple
casuals talk [ __ ] have some good food i
am a massive fan of that if we're going
out to
hammer a nightclub that's just i just
know i'm just know myself well enough i
just go see you guys i'm out and then
we're going i'm not [ __ ] going out to
that i'm just honest enough to say it
but time and place is good so i'm have
some crackers for example like we went
away on a camping trip with the tires
perfect you know you can't kick onto a
nightclub there so you just got to be
around each other
more for like the social
side of a social as opposed to the
kicking on and you're not remembering
the night no it's just not for me mate
fair enough mate i'm with you there
okay
um do you do you think his body will
survive another two years
so far it's been going so far it's been
going all right
touchwood but um yeah mate i'll be right
by then i'll be a couple more years you
know somewhere 29 at the moment so um
another two more years gets me to sort
of 31 so but even by that stage mate i'm
still um you know you've seen a couple
of hookers overseas that have gone to
like 35 36 so we'll just see
just keep going year to year as i have
and um just keep reassessing things and
how i'm feeling as i crack on love that
okay next one this is this is an
interesting one i'll be surprised if the
answer is no
have you ever lost a collision
yeah uh yes i definitely have um
the thing is in the uk everyone runs
straight so it's very easy to make um
collisions here you're going for a shot
again i think it was the cadence you can
probably find the clip
the canes ran like a just a normal i
think it was like off nine off ten shape
and i'm like square in front of this guy
so i'm like i'm gonna melt this bloke
they're just so athletic in new zealand
a little bit of footwork so i've
committed to a tackle complete he's
completely stepped me and run like i
think he's running like 40 meters we
play for canes
40 meters to score a try so i'm like
lying on the ground just watching him
run away
that's the difference you can't it's
harder here
uh because everyone no matter what are
just so much more athletic and they play
with such
more space
so it's just a lot harder to make those
collisions we're in the uk you're in the
mud you're playing between the 15s
so it's a lot easier to just plant your
feet and make a dominant shot um so yeah
okay last question this has been one of
the great podcasts but we'll always love
to finish with some advice what's the
best piece of advice you have for a
woodland listener
oh i guess
from my experience as a young fella i've
actually had like a couple of people
like reach out to me saying that
you know they haven't sort of made teams
what should they do what's
the advice of a couple of people like
early 20s say like what do you reckon
i'm not getting any love from super
clubs
i would probably just say persistence is
everything um
you can always make it work
you know you don't have to be getting
paid
solely rugby
to keep your rugby career going i think
that's like people see a lot of the i'm
either a rugged player or i'm not you
can do both whilst staying on task of
trying to be a rugby player to
eventually get that contract that
financially you can support yourself
i see a lot of people just kind of like
might say oh they haven't made it so
they're just gonna [ __ ] rugby off and
have a crack at after you can do both so
as a young fella
if you're similar you didn't go to rugby
school or you didn't get like the love
you needed or the advice
just be persistent with it do stuff
outside of rugby so you've got some of
your backups but don't sort of just give
up on it because the first couple of
years or you see your mates
making under 20s aussie or you see your
mates getting in super clubs like it
just doesn't
happen like that for everyone so
everyone's obviously got their different
stories so i guess for me mine was sort
of like my
persistence and hunger to like just stay
not worry about anything else know that
you have belief in yourself that um
you'll eventually get there and when you
do you'll look back and be like i'm so
happy that i didn't just throw in the
towel or i'm so happy that i also did
stuff outside of rugby because
you know i see a lot of people come out
straight from schools you know they're
signing people from 17 years old who
finish rugby they don't even know how to
do it they don't even know how to
open excel you know they don't know how
to send it like
do anything yeah so what's better i'd
rather go in
being a more complete person
than
solely footy is your life because you're
just you're mentally so dictated on
performance results at the end of the
game at the end of the day it's just a
game
and you know you've got the media that
go hard at people but it's just the game
at the end of the day so for those young
fellas that are
i guess struggling a little bit or you
know they might not have made a team or
a rep team
i can honestly say it does not [ __ ]
matter like you can make it doesn't
matter it's great if you make it but it
won't matter if you stay persistent to
it you will eventually get to where you
want to go to if you if you put in the
effort oh that is powerful wow what a
wow
incredible
absolutely incredible mate i knew it
would be good but i wasn't expecting
that much right genuinely i reckon it's
the most inspiring episode for any sort
of young player who's sort of coming
through the grades there's so much in
this episode um about how to how to sort
of make it through and mate you're a
perfect example of the way you've made
it through made a career for yourself
and look at you now mate i'm loving
watching you play for the tars and
excited to see you in that gold jersey
which injury dependent i'm sure is going
to happen um very shortly but oh we'll
see right like you say one step at a
time and um good luck for the tars for
the rest of the season
and mate it's been awesome having you on
the water lad because what a lad you are
well i appreciate it mate you're a
bigger lad than i am but um my awesome
thanks for having me and sorry it took
so long you know it's just a bit cringe
sometimes listening to yourself speak
yeah mate well i know your ocd schedule
it sort of took you two years to plan
this one
yeah
you've got two minutes actually okay
let's go you've got two more minutes now
i gotta go i'm gonna schedule today all
right cheers
[Music]
[Music]